- Hello believe nation,
I am a Tony Robbins fan
and I've learned a lot from his teachings.
And so I thought I would
start a new series.
I would test it out once a
month called Best of Tony.
Where I would take a video
that's made an impact on me
that I've learned something
from and share it with you,
and hopefully you'll
learn as well from it.
So, today we're going to learn
how to reprogram your mind and addictions.
Hope you enjoy.
- Who here is absolutely,
totally, completely
addicted to pizza?
You can swallow two or
three of them right now.
I mean nothing can stop you from pizza.
That's how much you want it.
A total addiction to pizza.
If you have that addiction,
stand up so I can see ya.
(audience shouting and clapping)
All right, hold it.
All right, how 'about, how
'about this gentleman right here.
Come on down, Sir, give
him a hand, come on down.
(audience shouting and clapping)
This is Bill, give him a hand, it's Bill.
The first point is you got to recognize
where you are currently
about the task at hand.
Whether it's running,
whether it's pizza, anything.
So you're going to assign a
numeric value to your experience.
You're going to say on a
scale from minus 10 to what?
Plus 10 where are you?
So, we'll say to you on a scale, Bill,
from minus 10 to plus 10 where
are you around eating pizza?
Plus 10.
- Plus 10.
- Is it just plus 10
or is it above plus 10?
- Plus 12.
- Plus 12, is that about accurate?
- Yeah.
- Plus 12, okay.
So then most people never
decide to advance the level
of quality, pleasure, joy,
excitement or even pain
that they're committed to experiencing
to a given task in advance.
So the second step is
to consciously describe
what feelings you want to experience
while doing a particular activity.
The third step is to decide and quantify.
You say I'm going to give it this quality,
I'm going to make it a level
10 experience, nine, whatever.
The fourth step to the right here
is you're going to ask
yourself the question
what conditions must
I create inside myself
or the environment in order to experience
this at level of quality,
at level whatever, okay?
What do you need to focus on, appreciate?
What do you need to do with the task
in order to change how I feel about it?
What we'll do here with Bill
is we will ask him where he is
and we'll get him to move things for us
and tell us what he has to
do to change it on the scale.
So Bill, if you imagine this is our scale,
from minus 10 to plus 12,
I'll have to add two more here for Bill,
okay, to plus 12,
what I'm going to do is I'm going
to put a pizza in front of him
and he'll describe for us a little bit
what are some of the
qualities that he needs.
So Bill,
here is a pizza,
a sausage pizza.
(audience laughing)
- Well first off, I don't
eat sausage or pepperoni.
- [Tony] You don't eat
sausage or pepperoni?
- I like the cheese and the
other aspects of the pizza.
- [Tony] Cheese pizza.
(audience laughing and whistling)
You know that you know
there's desire for this pizza.
- Right now, it's only a 10.
- [Tony] Only a 10.
It's only a 10.
- It's not really warm.
Well, imagine it warm.
- 10.
- Imagine it getting warmer.
- Can I imagine some mushrooms on it?
- Okay, imagine some mushrooms on it.
- Maybe a 12.
- Imagine it with mushrooms on it, warm.
- Sun dried tomatoes.
Dry tomatoes, mushrooms,
cheese, melted cheese.
- (laughing)
- Dripping with cheese.
- Extra cheese.
- What kind of cheese?
(audience laughing)
- What's your level of
desire at that level now?
- A 15.
- Okay, so extra cheese,
does that help him get in that state?
So let's write it down, what
does he do to get it higher?
Write it down on your little sheet here.
To get it even higher, what does he do?
He adds in his mind that it's really hot.
He adds in his mind
that it's got mushrooms.
And then to get it to the 15
he puts on extra what?
- [Audience] Cheese.
- Look at his face when he even says it.
Look at his face.
- [Bill] Cheese.
[Audience Member] Sun dried tomatoes.
- And sun dried tomatoes, thank you.
Now think about this pizza now,
and I want you to take
this pizza, if you would,
and put it down, if you would,
to level eight.
Go ahead and hold it with your other hand.
To level eight.
Tell me, what have you got
to do to make it level eight?
- Ummm.
- Plus eight.
- It wouldn't be warm.
- It would be warm.
- And, um, maybe it was just cheese pizza.
- Oh, I gave you the wrong one, I'm sorry.
I gave you the wrong one, didn't I.
- Yeah.
- There we go.
- If it wasn't really warm, if it was just
slightly above room temperature,
it would be an eight.
- Slightly above room temperature
which is about what that one is.
Okay, so that's an eight.
Bring it down to a three.
- It would have pepperoni
or sausage on it.
- Okay.
Hold both of them now.
It looks more attractive
when he's got more,
did you see his face?
- I just don't want to drop it.
- Okay, that's fine, no problem.
So make it a three and
it's got sausage on it
'cause you don't eat sausage or pepperoni.
'Cause after all, you're one of those guys
that has a pizza and a lite beer.
- Oh, I don't drink beer either.
- Oh, okay, you don't drink beer either.
Do you have a soft drink?
- Diet Coke.
(audience laughing)
- Before the seminar, before.
- I understand, I'm not on
your case, I'm your buddy.
- All right.
- But isn't that what we all do?
It's not just him.
You're like give me a
big extra cheese pizza
and a lite Coke.
Okay, so sausage.
Make it a zero.
What you should be noticing
is not just what he says.
Do you see the change in his head?
Do you see the changes in his breathing?
His facial expressions.
Is he in the same state, yes or no?
Is he even close?
Where is it now, zero to 10?
- Zero.
- So zero, it's been
sitting out for an hour.
Make it minus three.
- The pepperoni and sausage
and it's been sitting out for an hour
and the grease is kind of
coming out of the meat.
(audience groaning)
- The grease is coming out of the meat.
Can you picture that?
- Mm-hmm.
- Can you see that.
- Yeah.
And what is it with the cheese pizza
but it's still minus three?
And it had also mushrooms on it
and it also had extra cheese.
But it's still minus three.
And it even had tomatoes,
sun dried tomatoes.
But it's minus three.
How do you do that?
- It's been sitting out for a while.
- [Tony] How long?
- A couple hours.
- [Tony] How do you know
when you look at it?
- It's kind of glazed over.
I guess the sugar has come
up from the cheese on top,
and it's kind of glazed
over and maybe hard.
- [Tony] Getting hard, the
sugar has glazed over on top.
Anything else that makes it a minus three.
- No, that'd be it.
- [Tony] Okay, make it a minus seven.
- I can smell the meat kind
of rotting a little bit.
(audience groaning)
- [Tony] Smell the meat rotting.
Smell the meat rotting a little bit.
Where is it now?
- Minus seven.
Minus seven.
- [Tony] It's at minus seven.
Bring it down to minus nine.
But it has no meat and it's a minus nine.
It has mushrooms,
it has extra cheese,
it has sun dried tomatoes,
and it's minus nine.
- (sighing)
(audience laughing)
I'm kind of fighting the urge, 'cause,
I'd be smelling the rancid smell of cheese
in my stomach,
- [Tony] Okay, go ahead and do that.
- Well, I don't want to throw up here.
(audience laughing)
But I mean, I would get that urge.
- [Tony] You'll get the urge,
but I won't let you throw up.
(audience groaning)
- Tell us when you're at minus nine.
You won't throw up till you hit minus 11.
We won't take you that far.
But you'll be real close.
(audience laughing)
Tell us where you are now?
- Minus eight.
- [Tony] Minus eight,
take it to minus nine.
What are you focusing on
to take it to minus nine?
- The smell.
- [Tony] The smell of what?
- Cheese rotting, cheese.
- [Tony] Rotting, rancid cheese.
Can you see what it looks like too?
And smell it?
- I couldn't even look at it.
- Can't even look at it.
Go ahead and look at
it while you say that.
Look at the pizza.
- (sighing)
- That's it, just look at and think pizza.
Tell me when you're at minus nine.
Imagine mushrooms, extra cheese,
mushrooms, extra cheese pizza.
That's it, mushrooms, extra cheese pizza.
Where are you right now
on a scale of zero to 10?
Mushrooms, extra cheese pizza.
Smelling the rancid smell.
Look at the pizza when
you think about it also.
See it and smell it.
That's it, hang on, hang on,
hang on, that's it, that's it.
Mushroom, extra cheese, smell it.
Smell the rancid smell, that's it.
(audience groaning)
Snell the rancid smell,
that's it, smell it.
Smell it, there it is, smell the cheese.
You can smell it.
- Awggh.
- That's it, smell the extra cheese.
That's it, smell it.
Extra cheese.
I'd like some extra rancid cheese.
Where are you on a scale of
zero to minus ten right now?
- Minus nine, minus 10.
- Minus nine, minus 10,
don't go to minus 11.
Don't go to minus 11.
Okay.
Do you want it?
- No, I don't want it.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- So that looked like a fun
and hopefully valuable tool.
- So thank you guys for
what you're watching.
I'd love to know what do you think?
Did you like this video?
Did you learn something from it?
Do you want to see more in
the best of Tony new series
or is this a one-off and done,
never want to see it again?
Let me know.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really looking forward
to hearing your comments.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
Hoping you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see ya soon.